helping communities of color fight the
coronavirus
that's something the southern nevada
health district has been trying to do
through
special covit 19 testing sites now the
very first one
is located at all saints episcopal
church which is near washington and
valley view
orca mana joining us now live there
tonight with a story that you'll only
see right here on eight news now
well denise we got an exclusive look at
the kova 19 testing site here last month
when it was still being set up one of
its main goals is to serve this
area's large latino population it's now
been up and running for about four weeks
so we decided to see how it's been going
the folks that are coming out for
testing
they probably wouldn't have been tested
otherwise unless we
would have started the service here
helping our hispanic community the
southern nevada health district's first
emergency scope site
is at all saints episcopal church in las
vegas the outreach center has been
operating for a few weeks
and provides telehealth services and
covid19 testing
we have tested to date about 180
individuals of those individuals
we have seen about 70 percent are
hispanic the latest numbers from the
health district
show 30 percent of all kovid 19 cases in
southern nevada
are in the hispanic community experts
say that's due in part
to a lack of access to health care the
large latino population in this area
is why the church was chosen as a
testing site somewhere that's probably
not far from their home
or far from where they congregate and
also what they consider a safe
place the patient is able to test
collect their own suave
so we open it up we hand it to the
patient
the process is simple with results of
point-of-care testing available the same
day
they also added another testing system
where specimens are sent to the public
health lab
those results are ready in one to two
business days since the response
was overwhelming we wanted to ensure
that we were not turning anyone away
this is one of two emergency scope sites
set up by the southern nevada health
district and they also have a mobile
unit
that travels across the valley this
location is open on weekdays from 7 a.m
to 4 30 p.m reporting live in las vegas
tonight orco mana 8 news now